the undisputed tech king of melbourne is
a man named Ruslan Kogan founder and CEO
of Cogan com an online retailer that has
changed the way Australian shop we do
about three times more revenue per
employee than Amazon he's a rich
flamboyant controversial workaholic who
finds an escape now and again at the
Melbourne pier alright let's go catch
some snapper ok you must have been
around like eight years old when you
moved here from from Belarus or six
years old
communism is falling apart my parents
decided to leave which I'm so thankful
for and came here with 90 dollars in
their pockets kokin grew up in melbourne
'he's housing projects and showed an
entrepreneur's spirit right from the
start as a kid he ran a golf ball
cleaning business a car wash and then a
tech consulting operation by the time he
was 23 Cogan had become consumed with
another quest man's eternal hunt for an
affordable flat screen TV I thought you
know I can't afford it from the shops
but let me aim out some factories and I
thought I'd tell them that I want to
order a hundred thousand TVs and I'll
get back to me and then I'll ask for a
sample and that sample was gonna be my
TV but when they started replying with
all of their quotes I saw very quickly
that there's a brilliant market
opportunity here the big idea Cogan hit
on was to go direct to Chinese
manufacturers to buy TVs for a fraction
of the going price to get the first
batch of TVs Kogan maxed out a few
credit cards and had to borrow money
from his friends you're on this leg to
just get a cheap TV and it turns into a
business idea yeah
Australians had been slow to hop online
and local retailers had largely ignored
the web Kogan dragged the entire country
online and helped ignite an Internet
retail boom today
Kogan sells about 250 million dollars of
products per year and ruslan wants to
expand the brand overseas and make Kogan
a household name sure a check if we
still have a let's have a look yeah not
a single bot what do you think should we
keep trying or should we drink beer
thanks people keep telling me they feel
like Australia was a little bit late to
protect business but now it's turning
this corner you're kind of famous for
being outspoken and telling the truth on
things you know I can't tell if I'm
getting spun or or if they're really as
good of a corner
in turn look we went through a time in
Australia where our business leaders and
politicians we're talking about how bad
online retail is because it's gonna it's
gonna cost a lot of jobs in the retail
industry
I'm surprised they've already stopped
talking about how bad cars are cuz
everybody who used to make false
carriages has gone out of business and
luckily we're at a point now where
they're starting to realize that
innovation is the future there's only a
certain amount of stuff you can dig out
of the ground our brainpower and our
ideas are an unlimited resource and if
you can harness that one then you're
going to be a very rich nation